here's what i want to ask you though why
would you leave bollywood for stand-up
is that just like that's what it had to
be
i had a moment where i just kind of
fell in love with stand up again like
just like when did you start stand up
you're 2006 2007 really but like
when we started there was no like clubs
in india yeah india they say started
december 09. yeah so like what we had to
do which is just ridiculous you had to
book out a theater and then you had to
go up with like 90 minutes of new
material because they paid for an
evening right so you're just like blah
blah blah like no dynamics just [ __ ]
yelling for 90 minutes to figure out
what's funny and what's not and so i
kind of just did that for like four
years until the scene came around
and then i think
it was two things right one uh
i just fell in love with stand up again
i had like a good moment on stage and i
was like i feel more fulfilled by this
than the last six things that i've done
and then i did a really shitty movie and
like nobody wanted to work with me
anymore for like three three years and i
was like i'll just do the stand-up thing
again so started taking it seriously i
want to say
2011-12 like that's when i was like
now real quick question about bollywood
i've been told that there's a lot of uh
nepotism in bollywood yeah yeah very
similar to i don't know how similar i
mean it happens in america obviously as
well but like is it
the only way in is if you're part of the
family or if you're close to the family
or
can the average person get a getter and
i'm five foot eight showed up in bombay
with one suitcase if i get to be in a
movie anybody gets to be oh so you
didn't have any family that was involved
oh there you go there you go okay so
then so it's possible that the average
person could go out there and get a role
i think so yeah i mean it take longer
you'd have to audition it's definitely a
step up but
yeah it i'm not going to deny that there
isn't nepotism there's a lot of nepotism
in every industry we just get this one
version of bollywood and again i'm gonna
get like the most distilled version of
it so it's gonna the craziest things
that i hear um but yeah my understanding
was it was like a family thing and like
not so much i mean there's like talented
kids who are coming in from everywhere
what i always kind of balance that out
with is
i feel like there's more expectations of
fairness
in like entertainment industries than
any other industry like if a banker like
hired his own kid or if somebody else
hired his own kid you'd be like all
right he's just putting his family into
what he does but then suddenly because
it's entertainment and everybody kind of
feels like they could be a movie star as
well and had a shot you're like no
everybody should get an equal shot
including myself like secretly see
that's yeah that's interesting because i
always hear nepotism as an nri i always
hear of nepotism it's always family
family family i mean this there's like a
big league of bollywood which is the
a-list and that that is yeah you have to
be a star kid to be in that but then
there's
9 000 movies right below that which is
slightly cheaper but equally
entertaining and you get to be in those
so yeah i just look at like uh so at the
highest level it is neptunism
but there is opportunity to potentially
rise i guess i guess i kind of view it
the opposite when it comes to business
because like business can be so
cutthroat right yeah in in america like
if you're working for a bank or if
you're working for you know hedge fund
or something like that it's like you
have to increase the profits of the
shareholders and oftentimes the best
person to increase the profits of the
shareholders is not your son and
daughter
yeah it might be
a ceo from india
right who come in and do it where and
the problem with my [ __ ] knicks is if
you literally look at the board for the
new york knicks who haven't won in 50
years
it's everybody's last name is dolan sam
with the dallas cowboys james dolan okay
and and i think nepotism is the problem
yeah you can't tell me that the five
people who are best at increasing
shareholder profits all just happen to
be from the same family i know but
there's a big like indian tradition of
putting your kids into the family
business so i think you have to kind of
strike uh
you know uh
a middle ground between that like like
almost like if you have a farm or if you
have like a restaurant
like that's what we do you know it's in
our culture to put our kids into our
business so i'm not defending nepotism
right it's definitely an easier way to
get into a movie yeah and on friday
whatever the [ __ ] happens with your
movie happens like on friday nobody can
save you right whoever your dad is
whoever your mom is on friday if you
suck you suck and you're not getting
another movie so there is that uh but
i don't begrudge a father or a mother
the desire to put that kid in that is
the [ __ ] i love nepotism
no no i love nepotism and i love parents
looking out for their kids i see like
you know will smith putting his kid and
[ __ ] like giving them that opportunity
yes
anybody in that situation would do the
same thing yeah it's the people who
aren't able to be in that situation will
oftentimes go hey this is unfair yeah
maybe it's unfair but you might be in
that situation you would absolutely do
it you were in a movie with the
bollywood kid imran khan and now he you
know you're doing much better than him
do you ever want to laugh at that
[ __ ] no he would be like hey
he's the nicest guy
hey bum what you doing nothing but he's
like he's just one of those guys where
like you can put a camera on him in any
angle at any time of day and he [ __ ]
looks good you ever meet those people
who's just the camera yeah obviously
yeah at all times he's just one of those
guys
[Laughter]
so yeah he's he's not acting anymore but
he's directing soon expecting something
when he fails an actor but the point is
he was mean to my friend's friend so
[ __ ] oh my gosh
yeah [ __ ] him what did he do he was mean
to my friend's friend's friend
that's how things work over here he's up
choose a side anyway let me ask you this
what's going on with comics going to
jail in india because i'm here and it
seems so [ __ ] up
yeah uh for jokes they didn't do yes so
when i already went to jail for taxes
yeah
no man they showed up and said he heard
religious sentiments and put him in jail
and then
red tape and bureaucracy kind of kept
him in there for a month and there's
four comics that went to jail for
rookies
muslim comic yeah they said he made a
joke he went to jail and then the four
comics that were with him on the show
also went to jail yeah wow so like
you're in a country where you can go to
jail and then you this is what andrew is
kind of alluding to and you you walk up
to this line and you say what you can
get away with and then you pull back
how do you do that is that dangerous or
are you just not in jail because you're
not muslim i i have the most privilege
that you can get as a comic in india i'm
an english-speaking hindu uppercast
heterosexual man yeah so it doesn't get
better than that so if i'm not going to
talk about stuff a uh you know who is
yeah uh there are many comics who don't
have the privilege that i do or can't
afford the legal team that i do like i
got sued by lawyers for lawyer jokes two
years ago yeah
i went to high court to defend lawyer
jokes so like munawa doesn't have it
even five percent as easy as i do yeah
um so that's the reality of what it is
right now but hoping for better days
you